a good manager needs a variety of
approaches to get the best out of his
team sometimes you have to be firm put
that cookie down cookies are for closers
sometimes you have to set clear goals
Stacy be back the notes I can't read
what could say sometimes you need your
cute pace I'm working on Greenworks the
boss baby the temple goons were making
plans for their newest addition but this
baby has a big plan wee babies are
having a crisis babies aren't getting as
much love as we used to behold our
mortal enemy Oh No that's exactly the
problem
have you learned anything I mean no what
have you learned about puppies very
poppy no Jimbo puppies are evil Stacey
be better notes I can't read what could
say look serious oh it's like they're
having their own little meeting watch
desert humiliating you're going to write
them into this job I know how important
this mission is the company Niecy ha ha
Judy I got a deal the BK ID are you I'm
on a mission it's not enough love to go
around my job is to find out why he'll
give me a double espresso and seize it
someplace around here with these with
sushi I'd kill for a spicy tuna roll
right about now
it is
oh you're going to look the kids are
finally getting along that's nice
the final succeed with this mission I
will live here forever with you okay I
will help you but just to get rid of you
deal you come to me you know you're
watching thank you
okay shoot you on that how we can pass
the card I've never been so humiliated
in my life I don't Claire not owe
anything are done to me
what's all the racket isn't he adorable
oh I've got one for you too what bummer
DreamWorks the boss baby what that
cookie down cookies not for clothes
you
you